[Music]
why are we still here just give
somewhere every night I can feel not
coming
[Music]
and Maxim's rather believe in my chair
let's subscribe rate that one the
comments I lost
they won't stop hurting you feel it to
help you
I'm gonna make them get back up past the
comments on YouTube I'm going to [ __ ]
about the comments on YouTube once again
in 2014 I made the video what I deleted
my comments look at that beautiful face
nothing
nothing has changed since that date look
at it look at it 2014 oh and then after
meetings and meetings with YouTube 2016
let's fix the cup but they're all still
here they're all fell [ __ ] higher here's
how it looks like when I check the
comments it's like oh I uploaded a new
video oh I wonder what people say about
it because I worked a lot on it and I
want to know what people think these are
the top comments on my last video viewed
a page hello gross we have finally
passed 15 family members package emoji
now I got a small it's a bridge for you
search pewds 9 to 300 on Google what is
this [ __ ] Beverly Hills oh and while
we're at it by the way I don't mean to
change topic but can you guys shut the
[ __ ] up about my hair ok I'm going
through a rough period right now worse
ok this kind of tweets are not funny
this is clearly me you know it has my
avatar that has my name that is
definitely my name the spam it's getting
smarter it's like that South Park
episode it's getting even some smarter
and I know I know what you're thinking
what happens if you google skewed 9 to
trio first up awesome giveaway welcome
to pod give away anything thanks Lee
look at all that [ __ ] I'm giving away
[ __ ] no I wouldn't give they give that
away I'm a [ __ ] Swedish Swedish
bastard I'm not gonna give away [ __ ]
[ __ ] you holy [ __ ] I'm giving away Kylie
lip kit there's always 368 left I like
how it says copyright PDP team 2016
where the [ __ ] is 3pi team 2016 what is
your gender the trip I just assumed my
gender this is disgusting you know trick
my plant those one but assume they're
getting [ __ ] gender is just a social
construct that is my core message
everyone knows that it is clearly faking
I'm sorry release that who they say it's
not actually me Oh Lennox we're amazing
me I know what why are we still here
just to suffer and this is the comment
then every night I can feel my leg the
second comment is Johanna from Joanna's
standard Johanna standard more like
joyna
no standard [ __ ] hey if you're going to
be a fake girl at least be a [ __ ]
girl and not some cartoon [ __ ] image
Jesus Christ and at least if you got to
pick a girl pick some [ __ ] nice white
food you know like something I can be
like oh [ __ ] well I'd you know if I was
if that cartoon lady wasn't was a real
person I would definitely you know [ __ ]
so basically my comments right now are
just being used instead of me getting
comments from you bros that you can't
you spend time you talk to me and I want
to know what you're saying but instead
of that all I'm getting it's the [ __ ]
top common [ __ ] spam all three of
them I got a little surprise for you up
I said this before and I said it too I
said it three years ago let me pick if I
want people to use top comments or not
if we could just turn off top comments
this wouldn't happen I could just read
the comments as they go that used to be
the case here I love comments knew at
first oh wait so I can change it this
didn't used to be a thing before before
you could this is a [ __ ] thing with
YouTube like they have all these
features that they change but they don't
tell anyone how the [ __ ] am I supposed
to know about it Jesus Christ every time
it's like I make the grand video and
then used to be like but we have all
these features that you're bitching
about oh [ __ ] it [ __ ] works what the
[ __ ] why not tell me there's a point to
this video which very much ties into
what I'm about what I'm talking about
right now
but first let's review a couple things
that I think you might find interesting
so here's my comment section in the
jiggers thing so there's 1 million 1.3
million roughly common held for review
and then there's 240,000 marked likely
as spam and low dairy wrote loved it
YouTube is like ah
I love this guy Joanna Sita
he's been automatically been flagged as
spam on YouTube he says want to know
what a modern black man gets up to on
this date like here you know
[ __ ] you YouTube how dare you mark
Joanna Sita as spam I happen to very
much would like to know what a black
modern black man gets up to on his date
and then you know what I will click here
one view huh guess it's only me Ainsley
you're a you're a modern black man why
don't you tell okay let's watch oh good
god I love me just be loaded on the best
date ever
with the wonderful out of media oh god I
just say look how hard he tried look how
hard he trying to come okay he's
everywhere you could keep blocking him
it's not right it's not right damn it
these aren't even bad common like why
are you and Edgar so cute
nice nice profile take love your show
you're so good at art like why are these
being held like most of these are not
even spam I don't understand I don't
understand there there's also still
these girls posting in the comments like
hey subscribe my channel and I'll show
you my tea I found one yesterday her
name is Jo VFX and I think that's pretty
cool you know she's not just some random
girl posting nudes on the internet she
also had combines that with video
effects I said what a great [ __ ] idea
she's not just being a random slot on
the internet she's actually taken her
talent and her good looks actually if
you're gonna create a fake profile
around a girl at least six somewhat
attractive girls or at least a photo
that isn't like like this you know I
don't I wouldn't use this as my dating
photo that jay'll afbf shut the [ __ ] up
okay 4,000 people foot fell for this
second
that's porn on the internet let's not
keep it on YouTube 4,000 people wanted
to see jailed VFX naked okay well let's
click on her new nude oh how about that
that's it's an ad got to wait 5 seconds
5 3 2 1 come on come on come on
kama kama come off talk god damn it I
really thought that would work
this is what the comments are picking up
instead of reading as you bros write and
that's what is something I truly care
about Charlie must understand it
Aynsley thought said he fell over Jesus
Christ after last rant video I did
I basically requested that you could
just have moderator because I can delete
my comments and I can clean them up but
I don't really have time to go through
the later thousands of comments to make
them better and like you guys I seen
your birth complain a lot over the
comments not being good and filled with
spam but you can't help us but now you
can't it's time to change YouTube
finally added moderators actually ring
ring ring ring what's that YouTube it's
been there all along
it's another one of those features that
you didn't tell anyone about so I look
like a whiny [ __ ] again okay I'm
sorry
okay love you love you too okay
moderators do you want to be a moderator
for the 4th hot channel game sleep is
first first rank moderator
I am yeah at all and sleep as the under
all those months you guys if you're a
moderator you got the chance instead of
being a fan Drake do you want to be a
gnarly captain for the prototype
channels but now's your chance
comment down below our Luke kept in and
explained to me why you want to be a
moderator basically we're just going to
get a militant structure over the whole
channel so that finally in 2017 we can
in fact invade Norway I am getting tired
of Norway's [ __ ] and I'm starting to
think that YouTube and Norway are the
same thing
so now our looks Japan comment down
below if you want the great honour of
being a moderator on this channel me
the yen they're all will choose wisely
based on a couple things number one
great looks you need to be attractive
number two I don't want some mostly ass
[ __ ] I need to be a moderator because
I've been a fan of pork puffs for a very
long time no none of that there's no way
I can actually know okay so I don't want
your [ __ ] life just tell me something
really really really really great about
me number three what is Aynsley real
name if you can answer these three
questions I will pick you as a moderator
as an early champion and we can finally
hashtag make youtube right up again
actually number four this needs to be
your profile picture those are all the
requirements is everything understood
right now go forth my children and if
you want to shine like the Sun you'll
have to burn like it and we will burn
these shitty comments we will climb the
youtube comment section it will be purer
than no other rate I mean comment
section
this is getting weird isn't it alright
well that was this video hopefully it's
the last one I ever get to do about
common because it's get it is getting on
but anyway
why are we still here click on another
video just your supper
every night dr. Fields
also since Angley is general I want you
guys to know that yes you get after your
high rank ranking we take very good care
of our own
very good care